[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter
theory in this video we're going to be
discussing hoggle's flying instructor
and quidditch referee rolanda hooch
hooch is a british witch
who is speculated to have been born
sometime before the year 1918.
not too much is known about her and she
doesn't appear in the books or films
very much however she is a very
important character
as she is the one responsible for
teaching the students their foundational
knowledge of flying broomsticks
the ability to fly a broom is a
necessary skill for any witch or wizard
and hooch is an expert in fact hooch is
so good
that she was chosen as the hogwarts
quidditch referee by the department of
magical games and sports
being selected for that role is nothing
to scoff at and it's been expressed that
before you start the position
you need to undergo a series of
complicated and rigorous tests
both written and physical madame hooch
is known for her candid nature
flying is not unlike walking it's just
much more difficult
and far more dangerous and for her lack
of patience with regards to rule
breaking
none of you is to move while i take this
boy to the hospital wing you leave those
brooms where they are or you'll be out
of hogwarts before you can say
quidditch but one thing about hooch that
i happen to pick up on
beyond all of that is the fact that she
has piercing
yellow eyes their teacher madame hooch
arrived
she had short gray hair and yellow eyes
now
yellow eyes are not something that we
see every day in the muggle world
sometimes the whites of people's eyes go
yellow and that's called jaundice
but yellow pupils that's something else
altogether
and that's what hooch has the actress
obviously doesn't have yellow eyes
but her character clearly does that was
a conscious decision
so what's the deal why does madam hooch
have
yellow eyes it turns out that it's not
actually explained anywhere
so i'm going to give you guys a couple
of theories madam hooch is a flying
instructor and a quidditch referee
this means that a large part of her life
revolves around flying
it also means that it's extremely
necessary for her to have good eyesight
as quidditch is a fast-paced airborne
game
with a lot going on it's hard enough for
refs to see things going on in regular
muggle sports
so i can't imagine trying to ref
quidditch for her to be able to wrap a
game like quidditch
her eyesight must be impeccable far
better than a regular witch or wizard
so why are her eyes so good she's just a
regular witch
right my first theory is that based out
of necessity
madame hooch created some sort of
concoction or spell that allows her to
have
hawk like vision hawks are medium-sized
birds of prey
known for their vision they have four
types of color receptors in the eye
and this allows them to perceive not
only the visible range of light
but also ultraviolet light as hawks are
natural hunters of small animals
it makes sense that they would have
evolved to have such a keen sense of
vision
hawkeye is even an adjective that means
vigilant
having extremely keen sight and what
else do hawks have
yellow eyes so my first theory is that
hooch
who recognized that she needed good
eyesight to excel in her profession
created some sort of potion or spell to
turn her eyes into that of a hawk
my next theory which bears less weight
involves hooch being a metamorph magus
metamorph magi are witches and wizards
who are able to change their appearance
at will
metamorph magi are similar to anime guy
but differ in this way animegai
transformed their entire appearance
a metamorph magai possess the ability to
hone in on specific parts of their body
changing only those things becoming an
animagus
is also a learned skill whereas
metamorph mega
are born with their ability one known
in harry potter is tonks and we even see
her changing specific aspects of her
appearance
in the film tonks has no connection to
pigs whatsoever
but is seen easily turning her nose into
the snout of a pig
so why wouldn't hooch be able to turn
her eyes into literal hawkeyes
what do you guys think what's up with
madame hooch's eyes
let me know down in the comment section
below until next time
you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you